j'enregistre
est-ce que vous enregistrez
donc disons qu'un jour vous arrivez
chez vous ça a été une longue journée pendant
laquelle vous avez travaillé pas moins de 12
heures consécutives cependant
ce jour là une jeune femme vous a
dit qu'elle venait  sois en ta compagnie
alors que tu vides tes poches et que tu commences
à t'installer tu vois qu'elle est
téléphonée bien sûr tu lui
rappelles elle te dit qu'elle vient d'
arriver chez elle et qu'elle ne viendra pas
chez toi ce soir
à ça  moment compte tenu des circonstances,
comment diriez-vous
maintenant que vous faites un film
sur cette jeune femme
pour l'impressionner
montrez-lui comment vous vous sentez travailler sur le
film pendant des années et des pays à travers le
monde les premières écrans ici
et là et ici et là
et là les
gens disent de belles choses à propos de ce film
vous prévoyez de sortir le film corrigez
le mélange des couleurs le son éditez la bande-annonce
en fait vous le faites en ce moment
éditant la bande-annonce
vous faites cela pour lui montrer comment vous
f  anguille
pour témoigner de l'ampleur et de l'intensité de
ces sentiments
elle verra le film
sourire
mécontent
tu as trop simplifié sa beauté
tu